I see a lot of hate going on with
Cowboys and I don't know why the hate is
going on saying we haven't played nobody
those was both playoff level teams Zach
Wilson was the same QB last year mixing
with a little bit of Mike White Daniel
Jones he was in the playoffs last year
upset the Vikings went to the second
round the New York Jets is a premier
team and we can't deny them bro they
just beat a great Buffalo team last week
Jack Wilson helped them lead to beat
Josh Allen in the Buffalo Bills which is
a fantastic team so how can we say we
haven't played anybody I'm all about
what you have done versus what you're
seeing right now teams bounce back teams
face adversity winning National Football
League so anyone could get upset on any
given day man if your team don't show up
and play a complete Game it can lead
teams to hang around and play around we
don't want to play around with guys no
more we don't want to let guys come back
we want to bury it and we want to finish
them we want to kill them we want to
hunt all games and we're going to keep
coming and that's what it's all about
baby